Hi everyone and welcome to the toxic Google event.
And I would like to introduce Isaac.
So,
uh,
we are here for his book,
Eyes Wide Open.
Isaac was born with a rare degenerative disease of retina that caused them to
gradually loses sight despite all the hurdles that his did.
This,
this is brought upon him.
Isaac has led a very successful life.
He played visa,
answered by the bell.
He graduated from Harvard College at age of 19 with a degree in mathematics and
computer science.
He also graduated from Harvard law school and served as a law clerk for Supreme
Court justice,
Sandra O'Connor and Ruth Ginsberg.
He also transformed a struggling concrete subcontractor into an industry leading
with $150 million business.
And along with this he has also found hope provision,
which is a nonprofit for that funds the development of treatments for binding
diseases in eyes wide open,
which is part autobiography and parts of help,
Isaac Lidsky shares a very inspiring story of achieving success in his life.
So I'd like to introduce Isaac.
Excellent.
How's everybody doing?
All right.
Yeah,
I was gonna say,
I gotta hear you.
Cause I obviously can't see you.
I say that a sighted people are terrified of speaking to big crowds,
but it's blind folks are terrified of speaking to empty rooms.
So I want to know you're out there.
All right.
So I'm going to ask you to take a car ride with me,
uh,
this afternoon.
Imagine yourself taking a car ride with me this afternoon.
So let me give you the context.
You are 13 years old,
so I know for some of you Googlers that's not that far back.
But uh,
for others it's a while back so they take a second.
Think back to who you were at 13.
What was going on in your life at that time.
All right,
so you're 13 and your sibling has always been a little clumsy.
It's sort of part of her sunny absent minded disposition.
Um,
it's Kinda cute,
but not recently.
Recently,
uh,
there have been some pretty nasty bumps and bruises and some serious scares.
A tragedy was nearly avoided a couple of times.
It seems the problem has something to do with your siblings.
Eyesight.
Your mom takes you all to the neighborhood ophthalmologist office for a checkup.
Now,
there's nothing wrong with your eyes,
right?
Remember,
you're 13 years old,
so you're perfect.
At least you think you do.
You think you are.
And,
uh,
everything's,
everything's going well.
Nothing wrong with your eyes,
but still the ophthalmologist is clearly troubled by something he sees.
And he tells your mom to take all of you kids to the medical research institute
at the,
uh,
the medical school,
the university in town.
So off you go.
And after a very long day of strange and sort of a grueling eye exams,
the expert tells you that,
uh,
like your sibling,
you have a eye disease that causes progressive loss of sight and blindness.
So that,
that's what happened to me.
The sibling was my sister Darya.
The research institute was the Bascom Palmer Eye Institute,
um,
at the University of Miami.
It was 1993 and I was 13 years old.
Now before that day,
I was living a Hollywood fairy tale.
Um,
I was born to a middle class family and America to parents who loved me and
nurtured me and cared for my education.
I loved school,
came easy to me.
Uh,
and uh,
I enjoyed it very much.
And as you heard the Hollywood part,
I mean it literally,
I grew up acting.
I did about a hundred to 150 commercials,
got some lucky breaks here and there and,
uh,
it was ultimately cast as weasel wise l on NBC TVs saved by the Bell,
the new class.
I was the sort of Dorky character,
the nerd.
So it was quite a challenge for me as an actor
nonetheless.
Uh,
I played that role.
So that was before at the end of the long day at Bascom Palmer eye institute,
everything,
everything changed,
right?
Dr w called us into his office.
He took a medical textbook off the shelf behind his desk.
He flipped through the pages,
found the one he wanted,
uh,
put the book on the desk facing us and he pointed to some photographs.
He said,
those are pictures of the retinas of patients with a disease called retinitis
Pigmentosa or RP.
Rp Causes Progressive Loss of sight and ultimately blindness.
A diary and Isaac have RP and we'll go blind.
There are no treatments,
there are no cures.
We don't really know much about the disease.
Good luck.
That was it.
We got up and we left
and we got back in my mom's car for a long ride home.
So that's the Colorado.
Want you to imagine yourselves?
Uh,
take them with me this afternoon please.
So you sit in the back of the car,
your mom tries,
tries very hard not to cry with little success.
Your siblings are crying too,
and you are trying to make some sense of the diagnosis of the information you've
just gained for miles and miles.
So how do you feel and what is it that you're thinking in that car?
Fear is a powerfully destructive force in our lives.
Fear distorts all reality under the warped logic of fear.
Anything is better than the uncertain.
Fear will fill the void at all costs.
Passing off what you dread for what you know,
offering up the worst in place of the ambiguous substituting assumption for
reason.
Psychologists call it awfulizing,
right?
Fear replaces the unknown with the awful.
Now fear is self.
Realizing when we face the greatest need to look beyond ourselves to gain more
information,
to think critically,
fear beats a retreat deep inside your mind,
shrinking and distorting your view.
Drowning your capacity for critical thought with a flood of disruptive emotions.
When you face a compelling opportunity to transcend,
to thrive,
to overcome fear,
uh,
lulls you into inaction,
enticing you to passively watch its prophecies fulfill themselves.
So how did I feel in the back of my mom's car?
I felt terrified.
And what was I thinking?
I was thinking blindness will absolutely ruin my life.
Uh,
in fact,
I wasn't thinking that so much as I knew it.
I don't think I know it.
Here's what I knew in the back of that car that day.
Blindness will ruin my life.
Blindness was a death sentence for my independence.
Blindness is the end of achievement for me.
It means that I am going to live an unremarkable life,
small and sad.
Um,
I'm going to live that life alone.
No woman is going to love or respect me.
I'm not going to love or respect myself.
Um,
so I won't have any kids,
which is probably for the better because no child deserves that and in a sense,
uh,
I'm always going to be a child.
So that's what I knew in the back of that car that day.
Yeah.
Now,
fears work doesn't end with the baseless reality.
It can Cox in your mind.
That's where few fears work really begins to perpetuate this reality.
Fear must trick you into playing your part.
Now fears accomplices in this con or heroes and villains,
fear conjures up a world in which heroes and villains do battle for your fate.
Like a goddess of Greek mythology,
acting from Mount Olympus,
right?
Blamed your villains.
Fear will whisper in your ear the fault lies with others.
The problem is your circumstances worship your heroes.
Fear will admonish you.
They have the power to fix this.
They can save you.
Your heroes will make you happy.
The drama is epic and endless heroes and villains doing battle for your fate.
You sit back,
you try to take it all in.
You try to keep it all straight.
Yeah,
you're trying to figure out where it's all going,
but it's all smoke and mirrors.
It's a,
it's a diversion.
It's special effects.
Now,
what really matters is that you have become a cooperative participant in fears.
Reality,
right?
You play Nice.
You don't question the apprentice.
You abdicate responsibility.
You blame and credit others.
Meanwhile,
fear spell remains unbroken.
So my villain was blindness,
not with a lower case B,
as in the condition of sightlessness,
but blindness with a capital B.
There's a morphous boogeyman that was going to hunt me down and destroy my life.
My heroes were the brilliant research scientists working so hard to deliver a
cure for my disease.
They would do it in time.
They would save me.
They simply had to
living in the reality of my fears.
My life became a race against the clock.
I wasn't in the race.
I was on the sidelines,
right?
Uh,
watching his blindness was out way in front and only widening the gap.
Didn't look very good for me.
Now,
those were some really dark years in my life.
Then I learned to see through my fear.
I'm eyes wide open
if you can not believe it.
It began with my mother in law.
She's an unlikely heroine in the story though.
At the time she was the mother of my girlfriend Dorothy.
So
Brenda is an occupational therapist.
She was the director of occupational therapy at the Lucerne spinal injury
center,
or a typical patient was a woman who was thrown by a horse,
instantly became a quadriplegic.
Brenda's patient meets a with doctors and nurses,
had some surgeries mourns with friends and family.
Then she meets Brenda.
Brenda's job is the rest of the patient's life.
So Brenda assesses the patient's capabilities,
surveys,
the myriad tools and technologies that are available to supplement those
capabilities.
Right.
She develops a discrete solutions for concrete problems.
Maybe she a rigs up up homemade joystick to Maaco,
a homemade attachment to make a joystick on a wheelchair more accessible,
or she introduces tools to help her patient feed herself.
Grooming and hygiene,
getting an end of the bed,
reading a book,
right.
Take the problems one at a time,
figure out a solution.
That's Brenda's perspective.
So when Dorothy and I were dating,
um,
without us knowing anything about it,
re Brian,
it began to research some solutions for uh,
the partially sighted in the blind and one thing led to another and she found
Chris.
Chris was an expert in the field who are working in Boston where Dorothy and I
were living.
I went to go meet with Chris and it completely changed my life.
So I walk into,
I walk into Chris's Office,
um,
and right away she asks me,
Isaac,
do you ever use a cane?
I'm a little confused and I'm really annoyed.
I'm thinking of myself not,
why don't use a cane?
I mean,
I still see too well to use a cane and don't,
I mean he isn't.
She supposed to be the expert besides,
I'm not here to talk about candy canes,
like an arbitrary detail.
Right.
We were talking about blindness.
I say to her,
nope,
Chris,
I don't use a cane.
She says,
well,
do you bump into things and hurt yourself like an,
of course,
they bump into things.
It hurt myself all the time.
In fact,
two days ago,
I walked right into a fire hydrant,
a splitting my pants against my shin.
It bled a ton and it left me with a heinous Bruce.
So I rolled up the leg of my jeans,
showed the Bruce to Chris.
I said,
Chris,
yeah,
you know,
you could say,
I bumped into things and hurt myself.
No big deal.
I'm really want Chris to understand how little I care about bumping into fix
right now is not my problem.
Today is not my problem.
Bumping into things is not my problem.
My problem is tomorrow.
The future is blindness is my life is going to end right?
My problem is that I am losing my sight and there's nothing I can do about it.
Chris says to me,
you know,
Isaac,
if,
uh,
if you use a cane,
you'd bump into things less and you'd hurt yourself less.
Man,
it was an obvious point,
right?
Pretty obvious point.
Now.
I know you guys are all Googlers here,
so you're very smart.
I'm only a little embarrassed to admit it was such an obvious point for me that
day that it really,
it was like an epiphany.
I realized that there is only now.
There was only today,
this moment,
in that moment I saw that everything I thought I knew about blindness was a
complete fiction.
Born of my fears lies.
What did I really know about going blind or being blind?
Absolutely nothing.
What had I done to learn about it?
Nothing.
So I was trapped in fears tunnel,
unable to see the,
uh,
unbounded potential.
The vast landscape that lay just beyond Chris has pointed out.
The cane was a pinprick of bright light that led me out of that tunnel.
There was something that I can do right away right now today to make my life a
little easier,
to make my life better.
I caught on quickly,
I said,
what else can I do?
Chris had all sorts of ideas,
right?
Screen reading software to interact with my computer using my ears instead of my
eyes.
A technique called sighted guide to walk around with people a more naturally and
more safely,
uh,
techniques and systems to organize my clothing and my shoes so I could dress
myself and match or at least where,
what I wanted to wear.
Um,
simple solutions for discrete,
specific practical problems.
So I decided that day in Chris's office made myself a promise.
Whenever I feel afraid,
I'm going to ask myself two questions.
One,
what precisely is my problem right now broken down into its smallest,
most discrete,
most manageable for them right now?
What's my problem to what precisely can I do about it?
No heroes,
no villains.
Me.
Now word of caution,
you have to answer those questions for yourself in the vein of like cspan
coverage of some,
you know,
boring and mundane procedural,
a committee hearing or something like that.
You can't answer that question in the vein of a Hollywood blockbuster.
Okay?
There's no,
uh,
no action sequences,
no special effects,
oh,
soundtrack.
It's just dialogue.
No drama.
When I committed to answer those two questions for myself.
And that way,
whenever I faced fear,
my life turned around,
I took control of my reality.
I chose how I wanted to live my life and who I wanted to be.
Um,
I broke fears spell.
Uh,
I went on to build a very blessed life for myself on that,
uh,
uncharted terrain beyond fears tunnel.
Um,
I,
I did marry,
um,
Dorothy and I,
uh,
had triplets.
Uh,
and we,
we enjoy that so much.
So we had that had a fourth trial,
sweet baby clementine.
So a six and a half year old triplets and a 15 month old baby.
Um,
I'm immensely blessed and happy and fulfilled.
but if I had not seen through,
uh,
the reality of my fears,
I would have lived that reality.
I'm absolutely certain of that fact.
So I'm wanting to say it one more time.
If I hadn't seen through my fears,
I would have lived that reality.
So thank you.
Thank you so much for a great introduction.
Um,
I would also like to open the floor for any Q and a that people would have in
the meantime.
I have a question for you.
Cool.
Um,
despite all these hurdles,
it's,
it's very difficult to,
but imagine being in that situation that you were in,
um,
what kept you motivated?
So
the,
the way in which I lost my sight,
um,
it was,
it's a progressive condition if you picture like a jumbo tron screen at an
arena.
So imagine now that the sort of led bulbs on the screen are randomly breaking
sort of slowly over time.
And so you're watching my life as a movie on this screen.
And at first you might not even notice it.
Then it becomes annoying of certain parts of the screen are better than others.
Um,
it created all these bizarre affects.
Uh,
objects would sort of appear and morph and disappear.
If I got information through other means through my,
if someone told me what I was looking at,
then suddenly I saw it.
So the experience was,
was it was challenging,
um,
to put it mildly,
but it was also a real gift.
It turned out to be a real gift cause I got a peek behind the curtain and just
sort of the way the mind works.
And this,
this illusion of sight was shattered for me.
So sight is something we experience as objective truth as reality is something
that's out there,
um,
when,
when it's totally a creation of our own mind,
which is,
which is built on much more than just data from the eyes.
So anyway,
having sort of seen firsthand,
literally seen the way we are empowered to create an experience for ourselves
that is so immersive and complete that we then believe it to be true and
objective.
That was the sort of eye opening.
Um,
you know,
eyes wide open vision that like I said,
turned out to be the greatest blessing in my life because when we create our
realities in so many ways,
self limiting assumptions are fears.
Uh,
our misconceptions about success and failure,
strength and weakness.
Um,
the way we sort of misperceive luck,
oversimplify,
luck and on and on and on.
So,
um,
you know,
what kept me going was really,
at the end of the day,
this,
this a certainty that in every moment,
in every moment we choose who we are and how we want to live our lives
independent of the circumstances we face.
Absolutely.
You mentioned briefly about,
look,
how much do you think luck plays a role in our lives?
So there is,
there's no question that luck,
uh,
you know,
having,
it's a sort of sense,
it's beyond our control,
you know,
play a major factor in life.
I think however,
that we tend to,
uh,
if not misperceive luck and certainly oversimplify it
a so what do I mean
as,
for example,
the notion that there's good luck and bad luck or that there are events that
have an independent sort of value of good or bad?
I think the truth is a lot more sort of nuanced and complex and the events are
events and whether they're good or bad,
who knows?
And better than who knows?
It's kind of within our control.
So for example,
uh,
I was lucky to go blind.
Uh,
it may sound like a weird thing to say,
but in my experience in my life,
it was the blessings,
the sort of a perspective of the life that it has given me.
There's just no question.
One of the best things that ever happened.
Another way we tend to misperceive luck.
I think as we,
we again,
we,
we think that there's a pretty clear bright line between circumstances within
our control and circumstances without our control and sort of says we cannot
control.
And again,
I think the truth is really far more nuanced and complex really.
Um,
most things are kind of in that gray area.
Uh,
and we have a lot more control over,
uh,
events in our lives and certainly the way we experience those events,
how they manifest themselves in our lives.
Then we think.
Okay.
Um,
we have a question from audience.
Hi,
that day when you were 13,
when you got the diagnosis,
how long did it take for your vision to degenerate?
Um,
like to the point where you were gonna say legally find it and how long until
you totally lost your sight.
Sure.
So thanks.
That's a great question.
I mean,
the short answer is who knows,
it's hard to say,
uh,
this,
this really is this sort of progressive and sort of slow death of photoreceptor
cell.
So when did it start?
You know,
who knows,
when did it end?
Hard to say.
Um,
I know that when I was diagnosed when I was 13 at the time,
uh,
I would have said,
I see as well as any of my peers.
I'm not sure that's actually true.
I literally don't know.
And there's some,
you know,
little stories or anecdotes.
Maybe I was already starting to lose a meaningful amount of,
of,
of cells,
maybe not.
Um,
but so 13 wouldn't have said it had any problems in my mid to late teens.
It was,
it started to become a real nuisance kind of chip transitioning into a
disability.
Um,
and then,
you know,
by my early to mid twenties,
I was essentially living as,
as a blind person.
By the time I was like 25,
um,
I had really no useful site to speak of.
Thank you.
Sure.
We have another question from audience.
Um,
it's been almost 30 years since you've been diagnosed.
In that time.
Has there been any medical breakthroughs in this condition or is it still kind
of have a blindness sentence?
Well,
first of all,
it's been 24 years.
Sorry.
Definitely older than a motion people here,
but
it's not been 30 years.
Okay.
I'm sorry,
what was question?
No,
I'm so,
yeah,
there's been a lot of progress.
It's really actually quite,
quite remarkable.
Um,
without boring you with all the details,
I am convinced I will regain a substantial amount of site,
uh,
whether it's three years from now or five years or 10 years,
who knows and how much site and how useful,
who knows.
But,
um,
uh,
I tell all those sorts of researchers that I've been lucky to get to know over
the years that,
uh,
if I could see my kids faces,
onset,
that's all.
That's all I need.
And,
uh,
Dorothy has saved a lot of great pictures for me,
so I look forward to going through all of those someday.
Thank you.
Um,
I have a question for you.
So is there anything you wish you had known earlier in your life that would have
helped at least ease your struggles a bit?
Yeah.
You know,
it took some time to get,
you know,
to Chris's office and there were some dark years as I mentioned,
and um,
you know,
really call it denial or,
whatever it was,
you know,
it would have been nicer a little earlier on and maybe start focusing on the
practical,
immediate,
you know,
solutions to,
to,
to my day by day instead of really I'm
insisting that,
that my challenge began and then began and ended with the crusade for a cure.
Makes Sense.
Um,
do you have a question?
Okay.
Um,
I came to your talk today because I have to confess,
I didn't know who you are until two days ago.
Um,
and I read an op Ed that you had written,
I believe it's in the New York Times.
Um,
and you recounted an anecdote in which you were,
um,
making coffee in,
in the kitchen and the office.
Right.
And a woman came up to you and she said,
um,
here,
let me,
she,
she was going to sort of take over.
Yeah.
She took off her.
Right.
And you said,
you know,
I can make coffee myself.
Thank you very much.
And she says,
sure,
I know you can,
but you always put the grounds in the wrong bin.
They were recycling bin.
So,
um,
and like,
you know,
that anecdote sort of resonated with me because you know,
there are,
you know,
we all kind of,
when we interact with people,
you know,
perhaps there are certain set of assumptions that we hold.
Um,
and so I think in that anecdote you,
you sort of said,
well,
you know,
your assumptions were,
um,
I guess you had this sort of realization that an assumption you had made about
why she was intervening was perhaps wrong.
Um,
what would you say?
Okay.
Like what other kinds of insights has,
has,
like what other,
what,
what would you say is like,
you know,
if,
if blindness is a gift,
what,
what other kinds of insights would you say it has given you?
Well,
so
the,
the insight into,
um,
our
mmm,
are,
are awesome power.
I mean,
it awesome that sort of in the more literal way than the conventional,
the conventional user,
but our power to shape our own realities.
Um,
uh,
the insights that I gained into that or invaluable to me,
and,
uh,
such as had such a powerful,
positive effect in my life.
I'll say that,
uh,
I'm certain,
I'm convinced I'm,
I'm passionate about the fact that this,
this vision,
that sort of insight into the way our brains work.
It's for everybody.
It's not about blindness.
It's not about disability.
Um,
it's not even necessarily only about sort of challenges or obstacles in life.
Uh,
it's,
it's an opportunity to live with awareness and accountability and intention that
has been so liberating for me and so empowering in my life that,
that,
that's why I wrote the book.
Um,
um,
you know,
I wrote the book really because I wanted to share this perspective with folks.
Frankly,
I wanted to put it down in words on paper for my children to read.
Uh,
maybe when they get a little bit older,
more sensible because they don't make any good decisions today
about dot.
So,
uh,
I guess I hesitate to say sort of blindness per say is,
is the,
uh,
is the source or those sort of the locus of the,
of the,
uh,
the insight or the perspective.
That makes sense.
Cool.
Thank you so much.
What advice you would you give to people who are either going through this or
just in general for people?
Like there are lots of fears that everyone fears,
right?
It's not true.
It could be physical,
it could be mental,
it could be anything.
Um,
if you were to tell them small steps they could take,
you know,
to get to the point where you have been at this point,
um,
what would it be?
Sure.
I guess if we're talking about fear specifically,
you know,
uh,
as I was saying,
you know,
focus on what,
what's,
what precisely is the problem.
Break it down to small parts.
Focus on what you can do about it.
Search your life for heroes and villains because a,
they're there for they're figments,
uh,
in your mind that are,
that can be very pernicious.
Um,
generally I think that,
uh,
we would,
we would all do better to pay attention to the profound difference between what
we know and what we think we know.
Um,
we get ourselves to a lot of trouble that with fear,
but,
um,
you know,
the,
the fear stuff and overcoming fear is obviously is a key theme in the book.
And it's obviously what I chose to talk about today,
but really more generally.
Um,
it's this idea that whatever circumstances we encounter,
mmm,
what we do with them,
how we manifest them in our lives,
what we make of them is entirely within our control.
And for me,
I need no more sort of proof of that.
Then the fact that,
you know,
always there are people who have,
uh,
done far more with far less and been a lot happier doing it.
Right.
Okay.
So if that's true,
it just can't be the circumstances.
That's the problem.
Right.
Makes Sense.
Um,
thank you so much for your account.
It was wonderful having you here.
Thanks for inviting me.
Thank you so much for coming.
Uh,
I encourage everyone to read book.
It's very inspiring.
It's truly,
um,
it's an autobiography,
yet it's very inspiring.
Um,
I think I found it very useful and amazing to read through it.
You,
thank you so much for coming.
Thanks,
Ramit.
Okay.